OK, so now we finish our tour of Donald Trump's
weekend rallies in Nevada.
Donald Trump, again in this rally raised the
idea of a third term.
Now, I want to be really clear.
The reason this is notable is no longer because
Donald Trump really thinks he's going to get
a third term or is going to try to get a third
term.
He won't.
This is notable because it exposes his followers
as merely sheep who care about nothing other
than getting behind Trump, no matter what
he says.
Trump says fill the Supreme Court seat.
Sure, fill it.
Trump says I deserve a third term.
Sure.
Third term, Trump says, were the best on Corona
virus, no matter what the numbers say.
Sure.
We're the best on Corona virus.
There is nothing they won't cheer for.
And here they are cheering for Donald Trump's
suggestion of a third term.
Naturally slurring his way through the speech.
At fifty two days from now, we're going to
win Nevada and we're going to win four more
years in the White House.
And then after that, we'll negotiate.
Right, because we're probably based on the
way we were treated.
We're probably entitled to another four to.
And it should never happen to another president.
It's just a dishonest group of people.
But here we are and we're going to be here.
So that's the notable thing that the crowd
cheers, even if you like this guy, which already
signals a problem.
If you believe in the basics of the United
States, don't you have to boo the suggestion
of a third term because a third term is fundamentally
not what this country is about.
We revere George Washington for saying term
limits president, not a king.
But don't worry, guys.
It's just a joke, right?
Well, either way, the fact that he keeps repeating
it without a hint of sarcasm is a problem.
But what should really scare us is that the
crowd cheers.
Trump then went on to say that the biggest
problem the country has right now is the media,
not the corona virus pandemic, not an unhinged
lunatic in the White House, not any of the
other problems we actually have.
It's the media.
It's hurting our country.
The biggest problem that this country has
is the fake news media worse than the Democrats
because, you know, the Democrats are their
partners.
They play together.
Joe Biden spent the last 47 years selling
out America, off shoring your jobs, and then
Trump continuing to slur just very labored
speech calls Joe Biden a pathetic human being.
If Trump was someone that tried to talk to
you at a bar, you would sidle over to the
opposite side of the bar to China, and you
haven't seen the last of it.
Sleepy Joe Biden surrendered.
You know where he is now?
He's in his damn basement again.
No, he's in his basement.
He's in his basement.
But, you know, I can be bad to him because
he put the most vicious ad on television that
I've ever seen.
Do you know what I'm talking about, where
I'm standing over the graves of our fallen
warriors, our fallen heroes?
These are great people, the greatest people
there are.
And I'm standing over there and they have
some sleazebag reporter from a third rate
magazine having some source quoting me saying
I won't even use the term, but saying bad
things.
And there's nobody that loves our military,
respects it and the people more than me.
And they took.
And I didn't even ask.
We had 25 people that were witnesses that
are on the record already that have said that
never took place.
Fox News, you have Fox News, by the way, instead
of covering the Trump rally when this was
going on, they ran a segment on the impact
of singing Happy Birthday on the transmission
of Corona virus with a bunch of panelists
I don't recognize other than cultural critic
and arbiter of ideas.
Dave Rubin.
That's how bad this was.
That that's what Fox News was talking about.
Trump then continues to repeat this.
I don't even know where this came from.
This idea that Joe Biden wants to ban energy,
just ban it altogether.
And then we got hit with the plague, the China
plague.
And we're not we're not thrilled.
It's a disgrace.
Nobody should have died.
We got hit.
The whole world got hit.
But they stopped it from going into the rest
of China.
They stopped it from going into China, but
they didn't stop it from coming into the U.S.
and Europe and 188 countries.
So whether or not we allow Biden to impose
the biggest tax increase in the history of
our country, four trillion dollars or ban,
he wants to ban energy in America.
He wants to stop fracking.
Hey, by the way, completely ridiculous, of
course, ban energy.
But stopping fracking sounds pretty good.
I hope Joe Biden will stop fracking if he
becomes president.
And then Donald Trump apparently not getting
a strong enough reaction to that, scaling
up the unhinged claims about Joe Biden, saying
if Biden gets elected, there will be countless
deaths from suicide and Trump and Biden will
permanently destroy the lives and dreams of
tens of millions of Americans.
If he got in, we would have the greatest depression
in the history of our country.
I mean, I think 1929 would look like good
times.
All right.
Because he do everything wrong.
He'd raise your taxes.
He'd raise the hell out of interest rates.
He'd do everything wrong.
The Biden shutdown will permanently destroy
the lives and dreams of tens of millions of
Americans.
Inflict totally lasting harm on our children
and lead countless deaths from suicide.
Don't forget, when you do these shutdowns,
your state is shutdown.
You've got a governor.
You shut down.
There really aren't words to describe how
absurd all of this is.
Policy analysis.
Forget about it.
Even coherent criticisms of his opponent.
Even an accurate presentation of the facts
from which he can make his unhinged attacks.
Forget about it.
And then last clip.
I challenge you to make sense of this rant
about antifa.
I dare you to do it.
Take a listen.
And with that comes tremendous crime.
And, you know, I was speaking I was talking
the other day, darling.
Somebody just moved next door.
Who is it?
It's a representative of Antifa.
She will look at her husband, say, darling,
we're out of here.
We're out of here, antifa.
Remember, they were trying to blame other
people.
They don't like to mention the name Antifa.
I said it's antifa.
And I was right.
I was right.
They're bad people.
And you don't want to have to pay a price
for the damage and for the horror that they
have for our staff to pay a price.
And it's so easy.
What is he even talking about?
The rallies will continue this week.
We will have coverage of some of them.
Not healthy to watch too much of this stuff.
I will have coverage of some of them live
on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.